GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So can I begin with a few
words about the big picture
of solving
differential equations?
So if that was a
nonlinear equation,
we would go to
computer solutions.
And Cleve Moler is making
a parallel video series
about the Matlab suite
of codes for solving
differential equations.
Then when that
equation is linear,
as it is here, with constant
coefficients, as like the 1,
minus 3, and the
2, we can always
get a formula for the answer.
Involves an integral.
There's still one integral to do
involving the impulse response.
And you'll see that.
But there are few, the most
beautiful, the most simple
equations when the right-hand
side has a special form.
And that's one
possibility-- t, or t
squared we could deal
with, or e to the t.
We'll see all those.
Then we know what the
solution looks like.
For example-- first of all,
we know the null solutions,
of course.
That's when this is 0.
And then I just wrote for e to
the st, and I find s could be 1
or s could be 2.
Those are two solutions
with right side 0.
So we can match
initial conditions.
But we need a
particular solution.
And that's where this
one is especially simple.
So the idea is to try the form
we know the solution will have.
So I'm going to try a
particular solution.
When I see a t there, I'll want
a t in the particular solution.
But I also need
the constant term.
So I'll try a plus bt.
What I mean by try is put
that into the equation,
match the left side
and the right side,
and we have a solution.
And I'll just go
ahead and do that.
So there's several--
this video is mostly
about the list of
possible nice functions.
And that's one of them.
OK.
So if I put that
into the equation,
the second derivative
is 0 for that.
So I have minus 3.
The first derivative is just b.
Then I have plus 2 times y
itself, which is a plus bt.
So the left side of the
equation is just this much.
And it has to equal 4t.
And that we can make happen.
I see 2bt and 4t here,
so I want b equal to 2.
And so when b is 2, then
I have 4t matching 4t.
And then I have minus
3b plus 2a should be 0.
Minus 3b plus 2a, the constant
part there we don't want,
so that should be 0.
We already know b is 2,
so that's minus 6 plus 2a.
a is 3.
Now, that's perfectly satisfied
by b equal 2a equal 3,
and that's the answer.
Correct answer is
b was 2, a was 3,
and we don't have
to say try anymore.
We got it.
Done.
One other right-hand side.
Once you get a nice one like
this, you look for more.
If it was t squared,
we would assume--
what would we assume if
it was a 4t squared there?
We would assume a plus
bt plus ct squared.
We want to match
the right-hand side.
Now, a different type
of right-hand side
we know already.
What if this was e to
the-- say, e to the 3t?
Or e to the st. Let me put any
exponent there for the moment.
So now we have a
different right-hand side.
A very nice function.
The best function of
differential equations.
And now what we will try
with this right-hand side,
e to the st. We've
seen it before.
The particular solution
is just y e to the st.
The undetermined coefficients
were a and b in the first time.
Here the undetermined
coefficient
is capital Y. I'm just going
to plug that into the equation
and match the left
side and right side.
And I'll determine this
coefficient, capital Y.
So what happens when I put
that into the equation?
I get second
derivative brings down
an s squared, and first
derivative, we have a minus 3.
The first derivative brings
down an s, and I have plus 2.
All that is Y e
to the st, right?
I put in Y e to the
st. The derivatives
brought down this
familiar polynomial.
And it's all supposed
to match e to the st.
We can do that.
That's a perfect match.
The left side has the same
form as the right side.
I can cancel the e
to the st's, and I
discover that Y is 1 over
s squared minus 3s plus 2.
Good.
That's the coefficient,
1 over that.
Let's see.
I have to make two comments.
One comment is that s-- we're
totally golden if that s
is imaginary.
If s is i omega,
well, minus i omega,
or both, both
possibilities, those
will give us sine and cosine.
So we'll add those
to the nice function.
So the nice functions
are t, polynomials.
E to the st, exponentials.
Sines and cosines.
And you see this
worked perfectly.
Well, perfectly except
we have to be sure
that we don't have 1/0.
When would we have 1/0?
If s is 1, this would be 1 minus
3 plus 2, that would be 1/0.
I can't deal with s equal
1 with that assumption.
Doesn't work.
Also, s equal 2.
What's special about s
equal 1 and s equal 2?
Those make that 0.
They give the null solutions.
And I know that if this
happened to be e to the t,
and a null solution
was also e to the t,
I have to fix the particular
solution by giving it
an extra factor t.
Let me do that at the
end of the lecture.
That's the resonance idea,
where my null solution
is the same as what I hope
for the particular solution.
So I have to change
that particular solution
with an extra factor t.
Let me keep going
here to be sure we
get all the possibilities.
Again, we're getting a very
small set of nice functions.
But fortunately, they appear
quite often in applications.
Constants, linear like
4t, exponentials like e
to the 5t, oscillation
like e to the i omega t.
So let me make a list.
So polynomials, like the
forcing function could be t,
could be 1.
Constant, that would
be like a ramp.
That would be like
a step function.
They could be 3 to
the st, but not s
equals 1 and 2 in this problem.
They could be e to
the i omega t, and e
to the minus i omega t, which
leads me directly to cosine
of omega t and sine of omega t.
I'm creating here a list
of the nice functions--
polynomials, exponentials,
cosine and sine,
because those come
from exponentials,
and finally, I can
multiply these.
I could have, for example, t e
to the st. I could allow that.
And now, all I have
to do is tell you,
what form do I try to plug-in?
The form will have
undetermined coefficients.
I'll substitute in
the equation, and I'll
determine the coefficients.
So here we saw a plus bt.
That was good.
That was the Y. Here we saw
Y e to the st. That was good.
Here, what will I have?
If I have cosine, I need
the sine there also.
So I'll have to allow
a combination of those.
Say M on this plus N of that.
If I tried to do
cosines alone, I
would be in danger of taking
the derivative, getting a sine,
and having nothing to match.
So I'll take that.
Now, final question,
or next question
is, if I multiply two of these,
the product rule is still
going to tell me that
derivatives of that
have the same form as that.
Derivatives of
this t e to the st
have the same-- they also
involve t or e to the st,
with factors s, from
the product rule.
So what do I assume here?
Well, when I see t
there, I have to include,
as I did up there,
also constants.
And if I saw a t squared,
I would go up to t squared.
I'd have three coefficients.
Now, that e to the
st, I can keep.
So what I've put on
the right-hand side
is the right form to assume.
It's just like good advice.
Put that into the
differential equation when
this is the right-hand side.
Match left side
with the right side.
That will tell you a and b.
And you have the answer.
You have the
particular solution.
You have a particular solution,
and that's what you wanted.
OK.
And if I had t
cosine omega t, do
you want to see in
the whole business?
If I had t cosine
omega t-- oh dear,
it's getting a little messy.
I'd need an a plus bt
to deal with the t.
And I'd need a cosine
to deal with the cosine.
And then, just to make the
problem a little messier, can't
be helped, I'd need the sine.
So I need a sine omega t.
And I'm going to need
a c plus dt there.
OK.
I'm up to four coefficients
to determine by plugging in.
It uses more ink, but it
doesn't use more thinking.
You just put it in,
match all terms,
and you discover A, B, C, and D.
Finally, I have to say
that word about resonance
that I mentioned earlier.
The possibility that if
s happened to be 1 or 2
on the right-hand side,
that's also a null solution.
This method would give me
1/0, infinite answer, no good.
And we know what to do.
We know how to deal
with resonance.
So with resonance-- so could
I just finally complete
the whole story.
Resonance.
In this example, s equal 1 or 2.
What would I do with f
of t equals e to the t?
If that was the right-hand side,
that would give me resonance.
It's got the exponent
s equal 1, which
is also in the null
solution, e to the t.
So what do I try?
So I try-- everybody knows what
happens when there's resonance.
When you have this doubling up.
You need an extra
factor t to rescue.
So you would try y of t.
y, this is the particular
solution I'm looking for.
You would try t e
to the t, with a Y.
And you would plug that in.
You would find the right
number for capital Y.
And you'd have the
particular solution.
Only, I think, doing a
few examples of this,
you get the knack of
assume the right form,
put it into the equation, match
left side with right side,
and that reveals the
undetermined coefficients.
It tells you what a and b
and capital Y and c and d,
tells you what they
all have to be.
So this is a really
good method that
applies to really
nice right-hand sides.
Good.
Thanks.